[Music]
it bears not it Bears noting two things
rouf Daisy Khan and Sharif aamal were
invited to this event they could have
named The Format any way any shape or
form uh they refused to come that's the
first thing and the second thing is the
first te Momom is gone the second e mom
is gone they've raised no money don't
think that we're not making a difference
we're making it very very hard for them
that's not an
accident I'm sorry we're running out of
time so I the rest of the speakers we
have to keep short but I want to get
everybody in I'd like you to hear from
Joyce Boland who lost her son Vince um
and and and have her feelings uh shared
with you
good
afternoon good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen um first of all I'd like to
thank pamella for letting me come here
to speak and I would like to thank all
of you for being here and staying here
and listening to what we have to say
because we really need your help my name
is Joyce Boland I live in a small
suburban town called Ringwood in the
state of New Jersey I had a son his name
was Vincent Vincent Jr he was 25 years
old he he uh got his Bachelor of Arts in
business from NYU he got his um master's
from Stanford University in learning
technology he loved New York City he got
his Masters in May of
2001 uh in July of 2001 he got a job
with martian mlen on the 97th floor of
tower 1 his office was right in the
front
the tra
trajecta the pathway of the plane was
directly where his office was now you
saw that film you you can he I'm sure he
didn't know it was a plane coming into
the building but you can just imagine
the Roar and the sound that the people
that were working there heard they must
have been petrified I can only hope that
they were killed instantaneously that
they didn't feel anything
I am one of the lucky families if you
can call me that I did get some remains
of my son my mortician was given three
small brown man manila envelopes that he
would not let me touch them he would not
let me hold them to this day I'm sorry
that I didn't make him do
that one envelope had a little bit of
muscle one envelope had a little bit of
skin and the other envelope had a piece
of bone from his
scapular so you can see that my son 99%
of his remains remain at Ground Zero and
they will always remain at Ground Zero
100% of his Essence remains there all of
his hopes his dreams his goals are at
Ground Zero and they will always be
there this is a very special place to me
it's his final resting place it is a
place that uh deserves respect I go
there often in fact I even learned how
to drive in New York City just so I
could go to Ground
Zero um I go there sometime during the
week I go there during
holidays um I talk to him I feel his
spirit is there I pray for him I pray
with him and if you ever go there and
you see a couple of little flowers stuck
in a fence or in a hole somewhere it
probably is my flower that I put there
for him um I go there every 911
and I go there every Christmas Eve
because I'll bet many of you don't know
but on Christmas Eve there is a midnight
mass that said right out Ground Zero
outside whether it snows rains it's cold
it doesn't matter family members and
friends are invited to go there there's
just a folding table that's a makeshift
altar with a priest and he says mass and
that's where we go so that we know that
we can be close to him why is this
particular spot so important why does
the mosque have to go in this spot I'll
tell you why why I think it has to go in
this spot why they think it has to go in
this spot because yes it is symbolic
it's symbolic if they put this Mosk up
at the feet of Ground Zero it
overshadows ground zero and to me it's
saying we came we conquered and we
prevailed and you will always remember
this for your grave will forever be in
my shadow you ungrateful infidels yes my
was an Infidel because he was tolerant
he liked Freedom of Choice he was
hardworking he got an education and he
believed in the free and American
Enterprise
um I know that they're not calling this
a mosque what they want to put up I know
that they're calling it a cultural
center they're calling it Park 51
they're calling it an educational place
they want to put it up in they're saying
that they want to make friends with us
they want to teach us all about them
well if you want to make friends and you
want to teach me about
you then you are going about it the
wrong
[Applause]
way you don't take my hand one hand and
say nice nice come here let me show you
and you take the other hand that still
has open cuts and wounds in it and pour
in vinegar and salt and spit on it
because they're putting that mask up is
like spitting on the grave of my son in
the in where they want to put
it you know folks if it smells like a
rose and it looks like a rose and it has
thorns like a rose and this has a lot of
thorns it's a rose
there's also some other uh one other a
couple of other things I'd like to know
about this mosque I'd like to know where
the money is coming from where is the
funding coming for this MOS is it clean
money is it laundered money is it blood
Money blood money is my what I have what
I would think okay yes Iman fisel and
his wife Daisy are no longer the voice
of this mosque but they are still on the
council and they're on the board I mean
they're still on the board so I'll bet
it's like a trojan horse you know hide
it and you don't see it it's not there
but it is and then I'd like to say as I
wind this up that every year on 911 and
at Christmas since my son's death I have
written a letter to him and I would like
to read the letter to you that I wrote
to him this year on 911 I wrote dear
Vincent it is now
91120 we have once again gathered to
remember family and friends the three
bells toll as we stand and we hear the
name of our loved ones and that brings
forth our tears you are never forgotten
you never could be your memories will
live on in infamy the years have been
hard and there never is peace now we
have to put up with an Islamic mosque
right near ground Zero's feet we rally
and we fight and we try to protest but
they tell us it is religious freedom so
lay it to rest the powers to be are so
mixed up right now between money and
political correctness they expect us to
bow my heart and my head will never
accept this insult I am sure and I will
fight with my last breath to overturn
this Mandate of that you can be sure for
if we don't wake up to what is really
going on all around us today my
grandchildren and everyone else's will
pay the price in a terrible way the
radicals will win Seria law will prevail
and our loved ones death will have been
to no avail so ladies and gentlemen may
God bless us all and wake us up before
it's too late and if there is anything
that any of you can do to help the Stop
and to stop the building of this Mass n
Grand zero I would truly appreciate it
for I would like some respect for the
spirit of the soul of my son thank you
all very much